My name is Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
我叫亚娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。令我惊讶的是，通往这一职业的途径竟然如此之多，而且并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我感到自信，意识到我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的心理压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. If you're a teenage dad or you know one, you'll likely know how isolating it can feel. Too often people focus on the risks or challenges of becoming a young father, without seeing
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来了。如果你是一位年轻的父亲，或者你认识这样的人，你可能知道那种感觉有多么孤立。人们往往过于关注成为年轻父亲的风险或挑战，而忽略了
the person, the potential, or the positive impact they can have. In this episode we're drawing on real life examples and research to explore what teenage fathers need to feel supported and understood so that they, their children and the communities around them can thrive. I hope you find this a super useful listen. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm also a parent. I know that's not an easy role to grow into, even when I did it in my thirties.
他们作为个体、他们的潜力，以及他们能带来的积极影响。在本期节目中，我们将借鉴现实生活中的案例和研究，探讨年轻父亲需要什么才能感到被支持和理解，从而让他们自己、他们的孩子以及周围的社区都能茁壮成长。希望你觉得这期节目非常有用。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我也是一位家长。我知道，即使是在我三十多岁时才开始为人父母，这也不是一个容易适应的角色。
Today we're taking a really close look at an often not talked about group of people, and that is teenage fathers. We are looking at how we can understand the difficulties that they might come up against, and how we can help them and the societies and groups around them to overcome them so that everybody can benefit. Especially of course the children at the heart of these families and all families for that matter. I'm chatting today with Ali, an assistant psychologist. If you're watching on YouTube you might well notice that Ali's headphones suddenly disappear. We had a bit of a technical hitch which I think was actually my fault so I'm sorry Ali, but we have managed to get all of the content still together and I hope you'll find it really useful. If you do, please do drop a like, drop a comment. Let's really
今天，我们将深入探讨一个经常被忽视的群体，那就是年轻父亲。我们正在研究如何理解他们可能面临的困难，以及我们如何帮助他们及其周围的社会和群体克服这些困难，从而让每个人都能受益。当然，尤其是那些处于这些家庭（以及所有家庭）核心的孩子们。今天我与助理心理学家阿里进行了交谈。如果你在YouTube上观看，你可能会注意到阿里的耳机突然消失了。我们遇到了一点技术故障，我想这其实是我的错，所以很抱歉，阿里。但我们还是成功地保留了所有内容，希望你觉得它很有用。如果你觉得有用，请点个赞，留个言。让我们真正
get this feeling supportive. Let me know why you're watching and please do share this episode with anybody else that you think might find it helpful too. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this. Hi, Ali. Welcome along to the podcast. Thank you so much for being here. Hi, Marianne. Yeah, it's really nice to be here. Thank you for having me. Well, thank you for getting in contact with me and pitching this episode because it's most definitely something we haven't covered in the podcast before, nor is it something that I've never really necessarily thought about, but it's very, very important topic.
感受到这种支持。让我知道你为什么收看，也请把这期节目分享给你认为可能从中受益的任何人。我期待着在节目之后与你交流。你好，阿里。欢迎来到播客。非常感谢你能来。你好，玛丽安。是的，很高兴来到这里。谢谢你的邀请。嗯，谢谢你联系我并提议制作这一期节目，因为这绝对是我们以前在播客中没有涉及过的话题，也不是我一定思考过的话题，但这是一个非常、非常重要的话题。
Could you tell us a little bit about yourself and about the project you're working in at the moment, please, Ellie? Yeah, of course. So I'm an assistant psychologist, and I work within a team called the Family Nurse Partnership. Essentially that team works predominantly with young mums, so under the age of 19,
阿里，你能简单介绍一下你自己以及你目前正在从事的项目吗？好的，当然。我是一名助理心理学家，我在一个名为“家庭护士伙伴关系”的团队工作。本质上，该团队主要为年轻妈妈（19岁以下）提供服务，
and it's basically an enhanced health visiting service. So when mums under the age of 19 go to their first scan, they're offered the opportunity to engage with the family nurse partnership and they can sign up, it's completely voluntary, and then they get kind of regular appointments from a family nurse who supports them through the period of pregnancy and then also up until their child is two years old. And ideally, in the kind of ideal world, the partner or the father of the baby would also be included in that kind of package of support. But there are kind of practical and also potentially psychological barriers towards the partners or the fathers necessarily always engaging in that support. So my role was created, the kind of title of the role is Young Fathers
这基本上是一项增强型的健康探访服务。因此，当19岁以下的妈妈去进行第一次扫描检查时，她们会被邀请参与“家庭护士伙伴关系”项目，她们可以自愿报名。之后，她们会定期获得家庭护士的预约，护士会在怀孕期间以及孩子两岁之前为她们提供支持。理想情况下，在理想的世界里，宝宝的伴侣或父亲也应该被纳入这种支持方案中。但是，伴侣或父亲参与这种支持存在一些实际的，也可能是心理上的障碍。所以我的角色应运而生，这个职位的名称是“年轻父亲
Worker. And my role is to essentially engage the young fathers in the family nurse partnership and to offer a more kind of psychology based intervention as opposed to the more nursing based intervention that maybe the mom and baby receive, I offer psychological support for those fathers to prepare them for fatherhood basically and think about the type of dad that they want to be. So it's a pilot project and it's currently funded for two years. And yeah, we're kind of seeing how it goes and hoping that we can make a meaningful impact on these young dads and their families.
工作者”。我的角色本质上是让年轻父亲参与到“家庭护士伙伴关系”中，并提供一种更偏向心理学的干预，而不是妈妈和宝宝可能接受的那种更偏向护理的干预。我为这些父亲提供心理支持，基本上是为他们为人父做好准备，并思考他们想成为什么样的父亲。这是一个试点项目，目前获得了两年的资助。是的，我们正在观察进展情况，并希望我们能对这些年轻爸爸和他们的家庭产生有意义的影响。
So yeah, that's a bit about the role. That sounds so important. Have you yet got any teen fathers or are they still, are the babies still not yet born? Where are you at with that? So we, again, in an ideal world, we would like to start working with these fathers before their baby is born,
所以，这就是关于这个角色的介绍。听起来太重要了。你现在有年轻父亲参与了吗？还是说宝宝还没出生？你们目前进展到什么程度了？所以，同样地，在理想的世界里，我们希望在宝宝出生前就开始与这些父亲合作，
because we know that feelings of frustration and stress and anxiety really build in that period of pregnancy and it can obviously put a real strain on relationships as well. So ideally I'm starting to work with dads from as early as possible. Obviously there are some dads who for whatever reason haven't wanted to engage during that period and actually a lot of the time when their baby is born then maybe they might realise oh actually this support might be helpful for me whereas in the period where
因为我们知道，挫败感、压力和焦虑在怀孕期间确实会增加，这显然也会给关系带来真正的压力。所以理想情况下，我从尽可能早的时候就开始与爸爸们合作。当然，有些爸爸因为各种原因在那个时期不想参与，但实际上很多时候，当宝宝出生后，他们可能会意识到“哦，其实这种支持对我可能有帮助”，而在此期间，
you know the baby's not here yet I think they think oh you know maybe it'll be fine you know I don't need that support and then actually maybe they get a bit of a reality check when maybe they get a bit of a reality check when the baby does arrive. So there's kind of mixtures of when we start engaging with with the dads. But at the moment we only started the clinical work in January but we already have had a lot of referrals for this support. We've had a lot of young men who are really enthusiastic about accessing the support. So I currently work with nine young fathers and we have two more who are due to start any minute. So yeah, so far the kind of uptake of the service has been really enthusiastic and we've been pleasantly
你知道，宝宝还没出生，我想他们会觉得“哦，你知道，也许会没事的，我不需要那种支持”，然后当宝宝真的出生时，他们可能会受到一点现实的冲击。所以我们开始与爸爸们接触的时间点是混合的。但目前，我们从一月份才开始临床工作，但我们已经收到了很多关于这种支持的转介。我们有很多年轻男性对获得这种支持非常热心。所以我目前与九位年轻父亲合作，还有两位即将开始。所以，到目前为止，服务的接受度非常热心，我们感到非常
surprised about how many young dads have wanted to access the service. So yeah. Amazing. And can we just, are we able to say which area of the country or which trust you're operating in? Is that okay? Yeah, of course. So I work in Bristol and so I sit within Sorona. We cover mainly Bristol, but there are some dads who maybe are living slightly further a field whose partner and baby are kind of living in Bristol, but they may be living a little bit further away.
惊喜，没想到有这么多年轻爸爸想要获得这项服务。所以，是的。太棒了。我们能说一下你们在哪个地区或哪个信托机构运作吗？可以吗？好的，当然。我在布里斯托尔工作，隶属于Sorona。我们主要覆盖布里斯托尔，但也有一些爸爸可能住得稍微远一点，他们的伴侣和宝宝住在布里斯托尔，但他们可能住得更远一些。
And obviously we have to think about that as those cases come up. But yeah, most of our fathers are in Bristol and obviously Bristol is quite an interesting place to work. I would say there are real areas of deprivation and so there are challenges that come with that as well and I think even basic things like public transport in Bristol is not great so that can cause a real barrier as well to engaging some slightly harder to reach groups. So we've been navigating and kind of thinking about how we can adapt and respond to those difficulties as well.
显然，当这些情况出现时，我们必须考虑这一点。但是的，我们的大多数父亲都在布里斯托尔，显然布里斯托尔是一个非常有趣的工作地点。我想说，这里确实存在贫困地区，因此也伴随着挑战。我认为即使是像布里斯托尔的公共交通这样基本的事情也不是很好，所以这也会成为接触一些稍微难以触及的群体时的真正障碍。因此，我们一直在摸索，并思考我们如何适应和应对这些困难。
Thank you so much. So you mentioned earlier on some of the barriers for teen dads being perhaps involved in their future children's lives or maybe even their current children's lives if baby's already been born. Could you guide us through a few of those barriers, Ali? Yeah, of course. So I think we did a literature review at the start of this project because there has been some research into this subject, into young dads and the psychological barriers that they experience and the process they go through when they're becoming a young dad. But to be honest, it's very minimal. And as you touched on at the start,
非常感谢。你之前提到了年轻爸爸参与未来孩子生活（或者如果宝宝已经出生，则是当前孩子生活）的一些障碍。阿里，你能引导我们了解其中一些障碍吗？好的，当然。我认为我们在项目开始时做了一次文献综述，因为关于这个主题、关于年轻爸爸以及他们经历的心理障碍，以及他们成为年轻爸爸的过程，确实有一些研究。但老实说，非常少。正如你在开头提到的，
it's not an area that many people think about, or maybe in clinical psychology, it's certainly not something that regularly of regularly comes up as an area of research or kind of intervention. But what we know is that a lot of young dads feel like they are risk-assessed as opposed to viewed as a potentially useful resource. They often feel, so a kind of process that some researchers identified that is kind of specific to young dads is this process of sidelining, which is essentially where a lot of the package of support around the young mum and the baby is maybe quite intensive and really supportive and there's a lot of kind of charities and groups and support that
这不是很多人会想到的领域，或者在临床心理学中，这肯定不是经常作为研究或干预领域出现的话题。但我们知道的是，许多年轻爸爸觉得他们被当作“风险评估对象”，而不是被视为一种潜在的有用资源。他们经常感到——一些研究人员确定的某种对年轻爸爸来说是特定的过程——这种“边缘化”过程，本质上是围绕年轻妈妈和宝宝的支持方案可能非常密集且非常支持，有很多慈善机构、团体和支持是
young mums can access. But the father is quite often not included in that thinking. And often what actually happens is a lot of the young dads I speak to, if the only questions they've been asked by professionals are things about their mental health, things about kind of the basic things like where do you live, how are you guys going to navigate your co-parenting, or whatever it might be. It's very practical things. Whereas they're not often included
年轻妈妈可以获得的。但父亲往往没有被纳入这种考量。实际上经常发生的情况是，我交谈过的许多年轻爸爸，如果专业人士问他们的问题仅仅是关于他们的心理健康，关于像“你住在哪里”、“你们打算如何处理共同抚养”之类的基本问题，那都是非常实际的事情。而他们往往没有被纳入
in the narrative around, OK, what type of parent do you want to be? What's important to you? How do you feel about having this baby? And another thing that a lot of young dads experience that they've kind of talked to me about is a lot of people assume that because their pregnancy was potentially unplanned, that that means that it's unwanted, which actually a lot of the time isn't the case. There may be a period of shock, potentially denial, you know, frustration, feelings of
关于“好的，你想成为什么样的父母？什么对你很重要？你对拥有这个宝宝有什么感觉？”的叙述中。另一个许多年轻爸爸经历并与我谈论的事情是，很多人认为因为他们的怀孕可能是计划外的，那就意味着是不想要的，而实际上很多时候并非如此。可能会有一段震惊期，潜在的否认，你知道，挫败感，那种
oh my gosh, my life is about to completely change or I really wanted to go traveling and now maybe that's not going to be able to happen. Of course, there's that massive kind of upheaval when they get this news but actually a lot of teenage fathers kind of really resist this idea that they're having an unwanted child because a lot of them are really, you know, they're really passionate about being a good dad. They're enthusiastic about providing their child with the best life possible. And whether they're still in a relationship with their partner or not, they really want to make it work. And I think so often they're not giving the tools or resources to do that. And I think if we shift to starting to see these young fathers as a really useful resource
“天哪，我的生活即将彻底改变”或者“我真的很想去旅行，现在可能没法实现了”的感觉。当然，当他们得到这个消息时，会有那种巨大的动荡，但实际上许多年轻父亲非常抵制这种“他们有一个不想要的孩子”的想法，因为他们中的许多人真的，你知道，他们非常热衷于成为一个好爸爸。他们热衷于为孩子提供尽可能最好的生活。无论他们是否还与伴侣保持关系，他们真的想让它成功。我认为他们经常没有得到这样做的工具或资源。我认为如果我们转向开始将这些年轻父亲视为一种非常有用的资源，
to improve the outcomes for the whole family, then that could lead to a real shift in not only stigma and kind of societal expectations, but also it will lead to a better outcome for the child. So I think that's something that we've really thought about in our work and it's something that the young dads I work with are really kind of passionate about. So, so interesting speaking to you and just thinking about how important this work is really. At the moment, I'm watching a series on Netflix called Young Sheldon. In the current series, I think it might be series five. A spoiler alert for anyone who's not yet watching that series. Georgie, who is Young Sheldon's older brother, He is 17 and he was in a relationship with someone
以改善整个家庭的成果，那么这不仅会导致污名化和社会期望的真正转变，而且还会为孩子带来更好的结果。所以我认为这是我们在工作中真正思考过的事情，也是我合作的年轻爸爸们真正热衷的事情。和你交谈并思考这项工作有多重要，真的非常有趣。目前，我正在看一部Netflix的系列剧，叫《少年谢尔顿》。在当前的系列中，我想可能是第五季。给还没看那个系列的人剧透预警。乔治，也就是少年谢尔顿的哥哥，他17岁，他曾与某人谈恋爱，
and they are now expecting a child. And it's really been interesting because actually his character in earlier series was quite irresponsible. Lots of kind of butt of the jokes were kind of how silly and naive Georgie was, especially compared to young Sheldon, who was very, very intelligent. And it's been really interesting seeing him really rise into the role of a hopeful, excited, attuned, mindful, expectant father and how supportive he is being of the mother, even though they're no longer in a relationship, and how he's surprising everybody with his capacity to do that, even though he's only 17. I think this is the narrative that we want to really highlight, that it's not necessarily
他们现在正在期待一个孩子。这真的很有趣，因为实际上他在早期系列中的角色相当不负责任。很多笑话的梗都是关于乔治有多傻、多天真，尤其是与非常、非常聪明的少年谢尔顿相比。看到他真正成长为一个充满希望、兴奋、协调、正念、期待的父亲，以及他即使在不再谈恋爱的情况下对母亲是多么支持，以及他如何以自己做到这一点能力让所有人感到惊讶，尽管他只有17岁，这真的非常有趣。我认为这就是我们想要真正强调的叙述，即这不一定
about someone's age. Georgie has been fathered. He has a father and has always been living with his dad, but I'm guessing maybe perhaps for some of the families that you're working with and certainly some of the dads across the UK at the moment, they may be in the position where they're preparing themselves to become a father, but haven't ever really had an active or positive, supportive paternal role model in their own lives. Does that make sense, Ali? Yeah, definitely. And I think it's really varied, to be honest.
是关于一个人的年龄。乔治有父亲。他有一个父亲，并且一直与他的爸爸住在一起，但我猜也许对于你们正在合作的一些家庭，以及当然目前英国各地的一些爸爸来说，他们可能处于准备成为父亲的位置，但从未在自己的生活中真正拥有过积极、支持的父亲角色榜样。阿里，这有道理吗？是的，绝对。而且老实说，我认为这真的各不相同。
The dads that I work with, and some of them have really positive role models, male role models in their lives. And they have good relationships with their dads and when we reflect together, they can think about really positive memories that they have with their dads. They can remember kind of really emotional conversations they used to have with their, with their father when they were younger. And that's a really wonderful thing to be able to reflect on. And they're able to pick out the experiences
我合作的爸爸们，他们中的一些人在生活中确实有非常积极的榜样，男性榜样。他们与爸爸的关系很好，当我们一起反思时，他们可以想到与爸爸在一起的非常积极的记忆。他们可以记得当他们年轻时与父亲进行的非常感性的对话。这是一件非常美妙的事情，能够反思。他们能够挑选出
they had with their own father and think about, do I want to take that on as a dad? And do I want to be that type of father? Or is there a slight adjustment I want to make to maybe what my dad's approach was? And that's a really useful exercise for some of them. And like you said, a lot of the dads I work with have not had a relationship with their father or have had an extremely strained relationship with their dad or in fact, you know, both parents. And I think what's really interesting in terms of kind of thinking about kind of how they respond to becoming a dad is actually when they have a little girl. And I think that's been really interesting to see some of my dads who kind of maybe their
他们与自己父亲的经历，并思考：“我想作为一名父亲继承这一点吗？我想成为那种类型的父亲吗？还是说我想对我父亲的方法做一点微调？”这对他们中的一些人来说是一个非常有用的练习。正如你所说，我合作的许多爸爸与他们的父亲没有关系，或者与他们的爸爸，甚至实际上（你知道）双方父母的关系都极其紧张。我认为在思考他们对成为爸爸的反应方面，真正有趣的是当他们生了一个小女孩时。我认为看到我的一些爸爸，他们可能
relationship with their dad was based around being quite disciplined and maybe they experienced quite a lot of harsh discipline from their father. Maybe that was something that they, before they had a child, thought that they wanted and then they've had a child of their own. Maybe there are differences with raising a little girl and a little boy and we kind of reflect a bit on that and kind of different approaches and things that they can do with their daughter because a lot of these boys, you know, they're 18, 19 and in their mind, you know, they're completely overwhelmed by the idea of having to plan activities for
与父亲的关系是基于相当严厉的管教，也许他们在父亲那里经历过相当多的严厉管教，这真的很有趣。也许在他们有孩子之前，他们认为那是他们想要的，然后他们有了自己的孩子。也许抚养小女孩和小男孩会有所不同，我们对此进行了一些反思，以及他们可以与女儿一起做的不同方法和事情，因为这些男孩中的许多人，你知道，他们18、19岁，在他们的脑海里，你知道，他们完全被必须为
their daughter and they're like, I don't know how to navigate this because my dad and I just used to game together or used to watch football. And obviously not that girls can't do those things but they're having to kind of really think in a way that they haven't had to maybe think before. And I think we do a really interesting exercise where we think about the traits that their father had,
他们的女儿计划活动的想法所淹没，他们说：“我不知道如何处理这个，因为我和我爸爸只是在一起玩游戏或看足球。”当然，并不是说女孩不能做这些事情，但他们必须以一种他们以前可能不需要思考的方式去思考。我认为我们做了一个非常有趣的练习，我们思考他们父亲所具备的特质，
if they did have a relationship with their father. And then we map out this kind of quote unquote ideal father next to that. And we look at, we kind of make a list of all the traits of their father. And they highlight of make a list of all the traits of their father and they highlight and kind of move across all the traits that they want to bring into their own kind of father identity and they think about the ones that they want to leave behind. So a client I'm working with at the moment, his father did use kind of physical punishment. And he thought, and this young father thought
如果他们确实与父亲有关系的话。然后我们在那旁边勾勒出这种所谓的“理想父亲”。我们观察，我们列出他们父亲的所有特质。他们突出显示并列出他们父亲的所有特质，然后他们突出显示并移动他们想要带入自己父亲身份的所有特质，并思考他们想要留下的那些。所以我目前正在合作的一位客户，他的父亲确实使用了某种体罚。他认为，这位年轻父亲认为
that that was something that he agreed with. He kept kind of saying at the start, well, it works for me. Look at me. I'm fine. And actually, as we kind of discussed that idea of discipline, what actually became apparent is what he was talking about is he wanted boundaries for his child and actually it wasn't that he felt physical punishment was appropriate, he felt that he wanted to find a new way to set boundaries with his child and that was a really interesting exercise to think with him about okay how are there, what are the other ways that we could set boundaries with our children that aren't kind't that punitive,
那是他同意的事情。他开始时一直说：“嗯，这对我有效。看看我。我很好。”实际上，当我们讨论那种管教观念时，真正显现出来的是，他在谈论的是他想要为他的孩子设定界限，实际上并不是他觉得体罚是合适的，他觉得他想要找到一种新的方式来为他的孩子设定界限，这是一个非常有趣的练习，与他一起思考：“好的，还有什么其他方式我们可以为孩子设定界限，而不是那种惩罚性的，
don't use that punitive approach, how can we build that and we identified building that trusting and nurturing relationship with his child would help him to lay down those boundaries. That was a really nice exercise to reframe his way of thinking about discipline and all of those kind of things. So yeah, I think it's really varied how I work with the dads and think about their experiences of being fathered. It's a really mixed bag, really. That sounds so lovely. Like sounds really nourishing actually as a piece of work. And I know when I've worked with 17 year olds, not on kind of becoming a father issue, but a few of the 17 year olds have said to me, they have been young men, they've said,
不使用那种惩罚性方法，我们如何建立它？”我们确定建立与孩子那种信任和培育的关系将帮助他设定这些界限。这是一个非常好的练习，可以重构他关于管教和所有这些事情的思维方式。所以，是的，我认为我与爸爸们合作的方式以及思考他们作为被抚养者的经历是非常多样的。这真的是一个大杂烩。听起来太可爱了。作为一项工作，听起来真的很滋养。我知道当我与17岁的人一起工作时，不是关于成为父亲的问题，但有几个17岁的人曾对我说，他们是年轻男性，他们说，
this is just the best work. I know one of the, one of the sisters of one of the young people I was working with, they were all sitting having dinner together one evening and he said, oh, I've got my therapy with Marianne tomorrow and she went, all right. Is that something to look forward to, is it? Like, great. Are you not dreading that? And he went, no, I really like it. Like, she's really good and I really value our work. And it's like, actually, that's really powerful. And he would say to me regularly, everyone my age should have this. Like, because
“这简直是最好的工作。”我知道我正在合作的一位年轻人的姐妹，他们有一天晚上坐在一起吃晚饭，他说：“哦，我明天要和玛丽安进行治疗。”她就说：“好吧。那是值得期待的事情吗？就像，太棒了。你不是在害怕吗？”他说：“不，我真的很喜欢。就像，她真的很棒，我真的很重视我们的工作。”实际上，这真的很强大。他会经常对我说：“我这个年纪的每个人都应该有这个。”因为
you really hold that non-judgmental space, I can bring anything to you. We can pick that apart and look at it, but also having you not really know the people in my life, but also helping think about what might be my wants, my desires, my needs, my wishes, but also helping me find a middle ground and look at the kind of the darker fears, the things that might feel scary or they might feel guilt inducing and knowing it's safe to bring all of that there. So I guess probably you're doing some very important work along those lines as well as preparing someone for what we call pretrescence. So the idea of becoming a father and fatherhood. So I'd done an episode on Matrescence before, which is kind of the issue of kind of becoming a mother. But this is,
你真的保持了那种不评判的空间，我可以带任何东西给你。我们可以把它拆开来看，但同时你并不真正认识我生活中的人，但也帮助思考我的愿望、欲望、需求、愿望可能是什么，同时也帮助我找到中间地带，看看那种更黑暗的恐惧，那些可能让人感到害怕或内疚的事情，并且知道把所有这些带到那里是安全的。所以我猜你可能正在做一些非常重要的工作，沿着这些思路，以及为某人准备我们所说的“准父亲身份”。所以成为父亲和父亲身份的想法。所以我之前做过一期关于“母亲身份”的节目，这是一种成为母亲的问题。但这，
yeah, like an issue of Patrescence, which is making it conscious, making it mindful. And actually, yeah, like thinks, you know, all the baby magazines, I'm a mama of two, but all the baby magazines I read and the psychology forums I was part of and the Facebook groups I was part of when I was pregnant with my first really helped me in my journey in matressence to helped me in my journey in matrescence to mindfully transition to that motherhood role and to learn to become a mother, which included for me going along to NCT classes and things like that. But I definitely think there's less focus on that for men. I don't know of any magazines specializing in supporting expecting fathers. There are expecting father books aren't there but this definitely just for mine in my knowledge just isn't spoken about but it's such an important issue. Yeah definitely and I think just
是的，就像“父亲身份”的问题，这是让它变得有意识，让它变得有正念。而且实际上，是的，就像认为，你知道，所有的婴儿杂志，我是两个孩子的妈妈，但我读过的所有婴儿杂志，以及我怀孕时参与的心理学论坛和Facebook群组，真的在我的“母亲身份”旅程中帮助了我，帮助我在“母亲身份”旅程中正念地过渡到那个母亲角色，并学习成为一名母亲，这对我来说包括参加NCT课程之类的东西。但我绝对认为对男性来说，这方面的关注较少。我不知道有任何专门支持准父亲的杂志。有准父亲的书，不是吗？但据我所知，这绝对没有被谈论，但这是一个非常重要的问题。是的，绝对，而且我认为只是
touching on what you were saying there about kind of how that young person you were working with said oh everyone, everyone should get this. You know, that's certainly been the feedback that I've been getting. And I think what's so important about this work is they feel like, because this role has been created to work specifically with young fathers, I think they really feel kind of seen and heard and supported because my
触及你刚才说的关于那个你合作的年轻人说“哦，每个人，每个人都应该得到这个”。你知道，这当然是我一直得到的反馈。而且我认为这项工作如此重要的一点是，他们觉得，因为这个角色是为了专门与年轻父亲合作而设立的，我认为他们真的感到被看见、被听到和被支持，因为我的
role is really clear. I work with the fathers and there's not many services that specifically have that function. Of course, midwives and health visitors and family nurses can include the father in that package of support. But a lot of the young fathers I speak to, they say, my family nurse is great and I love sitting in the sessions. But the focus is still quite rightly
角色非常明确。我与父亲们合作，没有多少服务专门有这个功能。当然，助产士、健康探访员和家庭护士可以将父亲纳入该支持方案中。但我交谈过的许多年轻父亲，他们说：“我的家庭护士很棒，我喜欢参加这些会议。”但重点仍然非常正确地
on how mom's feeling, how the pregnancy's going, the sessions are around like breastfeeding, labour and all of these kind of things. But actually, even if the professional is, you know, really trying to include the father, there's not that space separate from their partner and their baby to kind of say, I'm actually really struggling or or I don't understand this, or you know, what's this? And we did, we partner up with a charity up north who are an amazing charity, work with young fathers and you know, they shared that actually a lot of the young dads they work with went through this really long period of having all these scans and midwifery appointments and things,
放在妈妈的感觉如何、怀孕进展如何上，会议是关于母乳喂养、分娩和所有这些事情。但实际上，即使专业人士（你知道）真的试图包括父亲，也没有那个与他们的伴侣和宝宝分开的空间来（你知道）说：“我实际上真的很挣扎，或者我不明白这个，或者（你知道）这是什么？”我们确实与北方的一家慈善机构合作，他们是一家很棒的慈善机构，与年轻父亲合作，你知道，他们分享说实际上他们合作的许多年轻爸爸经历了所有这些扫描和助产预约之类的漫长时期，
and then actually said to the people running the charity, you know, I have no idea what perinatal means. And everyone keeps saying this word to me, and I have no clue what they mean. No one sat down and explained it to me, you know, and maybe their partner has been reading the books and has been, you has been looking at the leaflets and things and Googling. But I think it is a bit different for our young boys. I think that it's not necessarily something. I don't want to make sweeping generalizations,
然后实际上对经营该慈善机构的人说：“你知道，我不知道‘围产期’是什么意思。每个人都在对我重复这个词，我根本不知道他们是什么意思。”没有人坐下来向我解释它，你知道，也许他们的伴侣一直在读这些书，一直在看传单之类的东西，一直在谷歌搜索。但我认为这对我们的年轻男孩来说确实有点不同。我认为这不是必然的事情。我不想做笼统的概括，
but it's not. They don't necessarily think to go out and seek out a book about perinatal mental health or whatever it might be, because they maybe don't feel welcome in that space. And again, going back to what I said at the start, they feel risk-assessed, they feel sidelined, and they feel like they're constantly being monitored. So it's really hard for them to ask those questions, like, really, sorry, I don't understand what's happening here, or I don't understand this part, or, you know,
但它不是。他们不一定会想到去寻找一本关于围产期心理健康的书，或者无论它可能是什么，因为他们可能在那个空间里感觉不到受欢迎。而且再次回到我开头所说的，他们感到被风险评估，他们感到被边缘化，他们感到他们一直在被监控。所以他们很难问那些问题，比如：“真的，抱歉，我不明白这里发生了什么，或者我不明白这一部分，或者（你知道）……”
they feel, I think, not necessarily because of the professionals, but just because of society as a whole, they feel judged, and they feel like they're not able to ask those questions. And I'm working with a young dad at the moment who, you know, his partner's family, you know, maybe have views that he doesn't get that involved with the baby and they have concerns around that. And actually when we sat down and had our session, just me and him,
他们感到，我认为，不一定是因为专业人士，只是因为整个社会，他们感到被评判，他们觉得他们不能问那些问题。我目前正在与一位年轻爸爸合作，（你知道）他的伴侣的家人，（你知道）可能有他没有那么参与照顾宝宝的观点，他们对此有担忧。实际上，当我们坐下来进行我们的会议时，只有我和他，
he said to me, everyone keeps having a go at me for not holding the baby, but no one has ever shown me how to hold a baby. And I'm, it's too far along now. My baby's, you know, however many months old, I'm now too embarrassed to ask, could someone please show me because I'm terrified that I'm gonna drop her or I'm gonna hurt her. And if you didn't delve deeper into what was going on for that dad, you might just look at him and think, God, he doesn't want to hold his baby, you know, that's not great. But actually, when you sit down and you talk with them about what's actually
他对我说：“每个人都在因为我不抱宝宝而责备我，但从来没有人教过我怎么抱宝宝。而且现在已经太晚了。我的宝宝（你知道）已经几个月大了，我现在太尴尬了，不敢问‘有人能教教我吗？’，因为我害怕我会把她摔了，或者我会伤害她。”如果你不深入挖掘那个爸爸身上发生了什么，你可能只会看着他，心想：“天哪，他不想抱他的宝宝，（你知道）那不太好。”但实际上，当你坐下来，与他们谈论实际上
going on for you, that's a really reasonable thing to feel terrified of if you're a 17-year-old and you've never held a newborn baby and no one's shown you how to, that's really scary. It really is such an important point and we ought to be able to, yeah, like hear whatever the fears are, but also dig for the real reasons that it might not be able to tell anyone else. But even, you know, I had a almost three-year-old when I had a newborn and even though
对你来说发生了什么时，如果你是一个17岁的人，从来没有抱过新生儿，也没有人教过你怎么抱，那感到恐惧是非常合理的，那真的很可怕。这确实是一个非常重要的观点，我们应该能够（是的）听到任何恐惧，但也挖掘出它可能无法告诉任何人的真正原因。但即使（你知道），我有一个新生儿时，我有一个快三岁的孩子，即使
I already had had a newborn before, I still didn't really know how to hold a newborn again because I was so used to holding like a, you know, almost three year old who's clambering all over me. Like, and if I was to pick up anyone else's newborn baby now, you know, I feel anxious about that as well. So it's just normalizing that's really okay. I guess you know people might be watching this either because they are aspiring psychs themselves or maybe because they are of themselves finding themselves that they're going to become teenage fathers or you know that maybe a parent of
我之前已经有过一个新生儿，我仍然不知道如何再次抱新生儿，因为我太习惯于抱着像一个（你知道）快三岁的孩子，他在我身上爬来爬去。就像，如果我现在要抱起别人的新生儿，（你知道）我也会对此感到焦虑。所以这只是正常化，这真的没关系。我猜（你知道）人们可能会看这个，要么是因为他们自己是有抱负的心理学家，要么是因为他们自己发现他们将要成为年轻父亲，或者（你知道）也许是与这个即将出生的婴儿有关的人的父母正在看这个。他们可能也不知道“围产期”是什么意思。阿里，围产期是什么意思的简要解释是什么？关于它有很多不同的语言，但（你知道）我猜围产期是分娩前后的时期，所以怀孕前、分娩。以及刚出生后，那是那个大致的时期。然后我们还有产后，也就是出生后。所以这显然可以稍微延长一点。然后我们还有产前，也就是出生前。显然所有这些时期都伴随着
someone who is kind of linked to this impending baby is watching this. They might not know what perinatal means either. What's a brief explanation of what perinatal means, Ali? There's lots of different language around it, but kind of, I guess the perinatal period is the period of around labor, so before pregnancy, labor. And just after, it's that general period. And then we also have postnatal, which is after birth. So that can obviously stretch on a little bit longer. And then we also have antenatal, which is before birth. And obviously all of those periods come with
对母亲、父亲和整个系统来说巨大的（你知道）动荡，无论是关于荷尔蒙还是（你知道）对分娩的预期。显然当你是一个青少年时，（你知道）很多（你知道）这不是你以前进行过的对话，分娩看起来是什么样子的，或者如何支持你的伴侣度过分娩，而且（你知道）我合作的许多爸爸的反应非常复杂，
massive kind of upheavals for the mother, the father, and the system as a whole, and whether that's about hormones or kind of anticipation of labor. And obviously when you're a teenager, you know, a lot of the, you know, it's not necessarily a conversation you've had before what labor looks like, or how to support your partners through labour and you know it's a really mixed response from a lot of the dads I work with
实际上（你知道）分娩对他们来说可能是一次非常痛苦的经历，因为你显然可以和某人谈论它会是什么样子，但它永远无法完全捕捉到当你（你知道）在房间里时，它实际上感觉有多么强烈和可怕。所以我认为，（你知道）出生后，许多这些爸爸处于一种真正的（你知道）震惊期。有时他们处于一种（你知道）对他们的伴侣刚刚经历的事情感到绝对惊奇的时期。对他们的伴侣刚刚经历的事情感到绝对惊奇的时期，在感到对他们的孩子和伴侣的完全压倒性的爱的时期。有时实际上这可能是一个每个人、所有事情突然感觉非常真实的时候。
where actually you know labour might have been really quite traumatic experience for them because you can obviously talk to someone about what it's going to be like but then it never quite captures how kind of intense and scary it can actually feel when you're kind of in the room. So I think, you know, after the birth, a lot of these dads are in a real kind of period of shock. Sometimes they're in a period of like absolute amazement for what their partner's just gone through. period of like absolute amazement for what their partner has just gone through during the period of feeling just like complete overwhelming love for their child and their partner. And sometimes actually it can be a time when everyone, everything feels very real all of a sudden.
这对这些年轻人来说可能真的、真的非常困难。而且我认为这对任何人来说都是一个极其困难的时期。但我认为当你那么年轻，当你以前从未经历过它，并且你可能处于（你知道）相当近期的关系中，（你知道）这些关系可能不是（你知道）长期的那种事情，然后作为一对夫妇或作为共同抚养的动态来处理它，那真的、真的非常困难。
And that can be really, really difficult for these young people. And I think it's an incredibly difficult time for anyone. But I think when you're that young and when you've never experienced it before and you may be in kind of quite a recent relationship, you know, it may not be that these relationships have been kind of long-term things, and then navigating that as a couple or as a co-parenting dynamic, that's really, really difficult.
是的，绝对。而且（是的）可能会有敌意。可能无论出于什么原因，男性被视为这里的问题所在。如果这是一次计划外的怀孕，实际上这是你的错。一些愤怒、不确定性和焦虑可能会被投射到年轻男性的方向。但当然，我们所知道的是，创造一个婴儿确实需要两个人，但这对于母亲、父亲以及围绕那对夫妇的所有系统来说，都是一个非常大的成长时期。只是在想，我知道这不是法律建议，但考虑到出生证明，以及父亲何时被命名或未被命名，以及所谓的“父母责任”，我理解得对吗？如果父亲在出生证明上被命名，
Yeah, absolutely. And yeah, there might be hostilities. It might be that for whatever reason the male is seen as being the problem here. If this had been an unplanned pregnancy, actually this is your fault. Some of the anger and the uncertainty and the anxiety might get put in the direction of the young male's way. But of course, what we know is it does take two to create a baby, but it's a very big growth period for the mother, for the father and for all of the systems around that couple as well. Just thinking, I know this is not legal advice, but thinking around the birth certificate and when dads are named or not named and what's called parental responsibility, am I right in thinking that if the dad is named on the birth certificate,
那会自动赋予他们在英国所谓的“父母责任”吗？阿里，你知道这个答案吗？我实际上不知道这个答案。但我知道很多，不是很多。我合作的一些父亲，在父母责任方面确实存在困难，当然如果这对夫妇不在一起的话。我合作的几个爸爸，有（你知道）人际暴力和家庭虐待之类的历史。所以当我们必须与主要支持妈妈和宝宝的家庭护士密切合作，而我支持父亲时，我们必须非常小心，我们进行了长时间的对话和非常仔细的计划，关于我们如何工作
that automatically gives them what we call parental responsibility in the UK? Do you know the answer to that, Ali? I actually don't know the answer to that. But I know that a lot of, not a lot of. Some of the fathers I work with, there are definitely difficulties around parental responsibility, certainly if the couple are not together. And a few of the dads I work with, there is kind of a history of interpersonal violence and domestic abuse and things. So we have to tread really carefully when I have to work really closely with the family nurses who are predominantly supporting mum and baby and I'm supporting the father, we have long conversations and really careful planning around how we work
与家庭围绕这一点，因为显然，我们希望他们发展出一种对宝宝有支持作用且对整个系统有益的共同抚养关系。然而，我们必须非常小心地平衡这一点与（你知道）保护方面的担忧。我们也必须与社会护理和（你知道）那方面的事情进行很多联系，以（你知道）为我们的决策提供信息。所以这很复杂，很多时候，（你知道）我合作的爸爸们可能看不到他们的孩子，就像他们希望的那样，但他们与伴侣的家人之间存在相当多的（你知道）紧张关系。
with the family around that, because obviously, we would like them to develop a co-parenting relationship that is supportive for the baby and beneficial for the system as a whole. However, we have to balance that really carefully with kind of safeguarding concerns. We have to link in with social care and kind of that side of things a lot as well to kind of inform our decision making. So it is complicated and a lot of the time, you know, the dads I work with might not see their child as much as they would like to, but there's quite a lot of maybe tension between them
所以这真的很复杂，而且肯定不是那种（你知道）直接的事情。这真的很复杂，需要我们这边进行相当多的计划和思考，我想。是的，而且我猜有时也会有家庭法庭诉讼，这样人们可以（你知道）正式解决他们的共同抚养问题。显然，就像你说的，如果发生过任何暴力或攻击，或者可能表明父母中的任何一方可能对自己或孩子构成风险的问题，那会更棘手。
and their partner's family. And so it's really complicated and it's certainly not something that is kind of straightforward. It's really complex and requires quite a lot of planning and thinking around on our side, I think. Yeah, and I guess also there's probably family court proceedings that happen sometimes as well so that people can kind of formally sort out their shared parenting. Obviously, like you say, that is trickier if there's been any violence or aggression or issues that might indicate that either of the parents might pose a risk to themselves or the child.
我们所知道的是，实际上证据向我们表明，孩子们在有协调、支持的母亲和父亲的情况下茁壮成长。你们在服务中为真正支持这些关系并允许年轻父亲自信地步入那个角色所做的工作听起来真的很棒，即使他们不一定在自己的生活中拥有那个安全的、不评判的空间和那些榜样。阿里，有一种你倾向于使用的治疗模式或方法吗？还是说你正在做的是更实际和（你知道）关系建立的工作？是的，这是一个好问题，因为当然，我的意思是，在（你知道）我们启动这个项目之前，我们确实有一段计划期。
What we know is that actually the evidence shows us that children thrive with attuned supportive mothers and fathers. It sounds really wonderful the work that you guys are doing in your service to really support those relationships and to allow young fathers to step into that role with confidence, even if they haven't necessarily had that safe non-judgmental space and those role models for themselves in their own lives. Is there a type of therapeutic modality or approach that you're tending to use or is it kind of more practical and kind of relationship building work that you're doing, Ali? Yeah, it's a good question because certainly, I mean, we had a period of planning, obviously, before we kind of launched this project.
我们所知道的是，证据确实表明，在充满关爱和支持的父母陪伴下，孩子们会茁壮成长。你们在服务中为支持这些亲子关系所做的工作听起来非常棒，这让年轻的父亲们能够自信地承担起这一角色，即使他们自己在生活中未必拥有过那种安全、不被评判的空间和榜样。阿里，你们倾向于使用某种特定的治疗模式或方法吗？还是说你们更多是在进行实际的、建立关系的工作？是的，这是一个很好的问题，因为当然，在启动这个项目之前，我们显然经历了一段规划期。
And what we've realized is it's really, it's easy to kind of plan what you would like things to look like. And then as we know, when you actually come to do the clinical work, quite often you think, particularly in a pilot like this, you have to have a bit of a shift or kind of realise, oh actually this is working and this isn't working and we've certainly had to do that a lot. You know, I work really closely with my supervisor who is a clinical psychologist and we think together kind of every week about what's working, what's not working.
我们意识到，预先规划好事情的发展方向其实很容易。但正如我们所知，当你真正开始临床工作时，特别是在这样一个试点项目中，你往往会发现需要做出一些调整，或者意识到哪些方法有效，哪些无效，我们确实经历了很多这样的时刻。我与我的主管——一位临床心理学家——合作非常紧密，我们每周都会一起思考哪些方法有效，哪些无效。
And I think what I reflected on a lot is that generally assistant psychologists role, at least in my experience, you kind of have a caseload and you have your appointments and kind of you have quite a clear approach that you're using. And what's different about this project is obviously what we've said from the start
我反思最多的是，通常助理心理学家的角色，至少在我的经验中，你会有一定的病例量，有预约安排，并且使用一套相当明确的方法。而这个项目与众不同之处在于，正如我们从一开始就提到的，
is 50% of it is engagement. You know, 50% of the job was always gonna be to try and get these dads engaged in the service. As you touched on at the start, these are young men who feel quite resistant to engaging with professionals because of past experiences or whatever it might be. And so we've had a long period of just building those relationships. I tend to work a lot outdoors, you know, we go to
50%的工作在于建立联系。你知道，这份工作的一半始终是要设法让这些父亲参与到服务中来。正如你在开头提到的，这些年轻人因为过去的经历或其他原因，对与专业人士接触感到相当抵触。因此，我们花了很多时间来建立这些关系。我倾向于在户外工作，我们去
parks, we go for walk and if not that then it's home visiting as opposed to coming into the clinic. So it's maybe a little bit more kind of informal than some other AP roles I've had before. And I think in terms of kind of the therapeutic modality we're using, I've used a lot of motivational interviewing. So I did the motivational interviewing training during the kind of planning phase and then I've used that kind of at the starting, in the starting sessions with these dads. I've kind of been able to use those principles to help them reflect on what they would like from the support, what they would like to move towards, what their goals are, what are the things that they might be doing that are keeping them stuck, what
公园，去散步，如果不行，就进行家访，而不是让他们来诊所。所以这可能比我之前担任的其他助理心理学家职位更非正式一些。关于我们使用的治疗方式，我使用了大量的动机访谈法。我在规划阶段完成了动机访谈培训，然后在与这些父亲的初步会谈中使用了这种方法。我能够运用这些原则帮助他们反思自己希望从支持中获得什么，他们想朝着什么方向努力，他们的目标是什么，以及他们可能正在做哪些事情导致自己陷入困境，
are their protective factors, what are their strengths, and all those kind of things. And then now we're moving slightly more into the kind of intervention part of the work, I suppose. And although that is still really flexible, it's really led by the father themselves because as I said, it's all about engagement and keeping them engaged and keeping them kind of talking and reflecting. So I'm really flexible, but we are mainly using kind
他们的保护因素是什么，他们的优势是什么，以及所有这些方面。现在我们正逐渐进入工作的干预部分。虽然这仍然非常灵活，但主要是由父亲们自己主导的，因为正如我所说，一切都是为了建立联系，让他们保持参与，让他们持续交流和反思。所以我非常灵活，但我们主要使用的是
of an acceptance and commitment therapy type approach. And that's mixed in with some other kind of resources that the Family Nurse Partnership in general use as well. So we're kind of using a bit of a mismatch of things, but with the acceptance and commitment therapy approach, I think what we realised quite early on is a lot of these dads have quite strong pre-existing beliefs about themselves, about potentially feeling like they're not good enough, feeling like they don't know what they're doing, feeling like they don't have enough confidence or skill or knowledge to be a dad. And I think an acceptance and commitment approach is helping them to identify their values,
一种接纳与承诺疗法（ACT）。这与家庭护士伙伴关系（Family Nurse Partnership）通常使用的一些其他资源相结合。所以我们使用了一种混合的方法，但通过接纳与承诺疗法，我们很早就意识到，许多父亲对自己有着非常强烈的既定信念，比如觉得自己不够好，觉得自己不知道自己在做什么，觉得自己没有足够的自信、技能或知识来成为一名父亲。我认为接纳与承诺疗法正在帮助他们识别自己的价值观，
to think kind of in a more general way about the things that might have happened in the past that maybe they would like to leave behind and not bring with them and think about kind of new directions and where they want to move forward. And I think we thought briefly about a slightly more kind of that traditional CBT based approach, but what seems to be working really well What seems to be working really well is having kind of a slightly more flexible approach and an approach that can be used when we're out on walks
以更宏观的方式思考过去可能发生的事情，也许他们想把这些抛在脑后，不再带着它们前行，并思考新的方向以及他们想要前进的目标。我们曾简要考虑过更传统的认知行为疗法（CBT），但目前看来效果非常好的是一种稍微灵活一点的方法，一种可以在我们散步时使用的方法，
and can be used when we're sat in the park or whatever it might be. And so we felt that maybe acceptance and commitment therapy would work a little bit better in those settings. And it's something that can be a little bit better in those settings and it's something that can be a little bit more creative as well. So that's the approach we're kind of using at the moment but we're kind of assessing and reviewing all the time. So it may be that our approach slightly changes but yeah that's kind of what we're using at the moment. Brilliant. Thank you. That's really helpful for clarifying that. If there was a teenage
也可以在我们坐在公园里或任何其他地方时使用。因此，我们觉得接纳与承诺疗法在这些环境中可能效果更好。它也更具创造性。这就是我们目前使用的方法，但我们一直在评估和审查。所以我们的方法可能会有轻微的改变，但这就是我们目前正在使用的。太棒了。谢谢。这非常有帮助，澄清了这一点。如果有一位青少年
father watching this or someone that's due to become a teenage father, are there maybe a couple of pieces of advice or kind of reassurance that might be helpful for him to be hearing and seeing right now? Ali, sorry to put you on the spot with that. Do take a moment to think about that if that would be helpful for him to be hearing and seeing right now, Ali? Sorry to put you on the spot with that. Do take a moment to think about that, if that would be helpful. No, I think it's a really important thing to ask. I think that what we obviously, I'm by no means an expert, but what I've done a lot of the reading around the research and obviously I've done a lot of the practical clinical work myself as well. I think what I would say is that finding some kind of neutral space potentially away from from your family or your partner,
父亲正在看这个节目，或者有人即将成为青少年父亲，有没有什么建议或安慰的话对他现在听到和看到会有帮助？阿里，抱歉让你当场回答这个问题。如果这对你有帮助，请花点时间思考一下。不，我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。我绝不是专家，但我阅读了大量研究资料，当然我自己也做了很多实际的临床工作。我想说的是，找到一个中立的空间，可能远离你的家人或伴侣，
finding a supportive space that you can access that just gives you a bit of a sense of community. I think that's really important. There are things emerging across the country that are not only specifically for dads, but there are also kind of charities that are working specifically with young dads. And there are some really great resources, websites, apps, social media pages and things. So whether it's even like an Instagram page
找到一个你可以进入的支持性空间，这会给你一种社区感。我认为这非常重要。全国各地正在涌现出一些不仅专门针对父亲，而且还有专门致力于帮助年轻父亲的慈善机构。还有一些非常棒的资源、网站、应用程序、社交媒体页面等。所以，即使只是一个Instagram页面，
that you can look at that kind of has information about being a young dad or kind of reassuring messages or speaks about other young dads' personal experiences. I think that knowing that you're not alone in how you're feeling is always really important for anything. But I think particularly when you're a young father, it is a small group and it is a very unique experience. We know that the things that young fathers go through, it is slightly different to what older fathers go through. There are really specific kind of psychological things that occur for young fathers specifically. So I think it's really valuable to be able to find other people who can relate to your experiences. And, you know, I can maybe share the details of those charities or something,
你也可以查看，上面有关于成为年轻父亲的信息，或者一些安慰性的信息，或者讲述其他年轻父亲的个人经历。我认为知道你在感受上并不孤单，这对任何事情都很重要。但特别是在你成为年轻父亲时，这是一个很小的群体，也是一种非常独特的经历。我们知道年轻父亲所经历的事情与年长父亲略有不同。年轻父亲确实会经历一些非常具体的心理过程。所以我认为能够找到其他能理解你经历的人是非常有价值的。而且，我可以分享这些慈善机构的详细信息，
and maybe put it somewhere that would be helpful. But I think that would be my first piece of advice. And secondly, to kind of try, if you can, to kind of speak up for yourself as well in the situations where you are feeling sidelined or you're feeling risk-assessed. Don't be afraid to ask important questions. If you're feeling really confused about the language people are using, if you struggle to understand the level of information that is being told to you if you're, you know, attending an antenatal class with your partner or your midwifery appointment or whatever it might be. I think, you know, don't be afraid to advocate for yourself and find other people who can also advocate for you. So if you've got a family member who can maybe support you with appointments or support you with a phone call
也许把它们放在一个有帮助的地方。但我想这是我的第一个建议。其次，如果可以的话，在感到被边缘化或被风险评估时，也要试着为自己发声。不要害怕问重要的问题。如果你对人们使用的语言感到困惑，如果你在与伴侣参加产前课程或助产士预约时，难以理解所告知的信息，我认为，不要害怕为自己辩护，并找到其他人来为你辩护。所以，如果你有一位家庭成员可以在预约或电话中支持你，
Or you can speak to your GP if you're feeling low or anxious or whatever it might be. I think just being able to Really? Realize that you are a valuable resource for your family, but also for your child. And we know all the research points, as you touched on, to the fact that when children have attuned, nurturing present fathers around, that results in really positive outcomes for children. So know that you are a really important piece of the puzzle,
或者如果你感到情绪低落或焦虑，可以咨询你的全科医生。我认为，能够意识到你是家庭的重要资源，对你的孩子也是如此，这一点非常重要。正如你提到的，所有研究都表明，当孩子身边有协调、养育、在场的父亲时，会给孩子带来非常积极的结果。所以要知道，你是拼图中非常重要的一块，
even if you don't feel like it. And hopefully it's kind of a bit of a cycle really, because if more young fathers speak up about feeling sidelined or risk-assessed, then hopefully that will feed into the wider narrative around people thinking more about young fathers or fathers in general and thinking about changing policies and changing the way we work with dads.
即使你感觉不到。希望这能形成一个良性循环，因为如果有更多的年轻父亲站出来表达自己感到被边缘化或被风险评估，那么希望这会影响更广泛的叙事，让人们更多地思考年轻父亲或父亲群体，并考虑改变政策和我们与父亲合作的方式。
And hopefully it will kind of be that sort of symbiotic relationship where one feeds into the other and eventually will be in a place where fathers are viewed as just as much of an important resource as mums are. I think that it's really important. They're my main pieces of advice, I think. I hope that has helped. Absolutely. They're really, really useful. I think to obviously underpin everything you've said, but perhaps think about some other bits and pieces as well. It's like it's never too late. Even if your baby is one, two, three, you've got a young child that's about to start school, you've only met them a few times, it's never
希望这能成为一种共生关系，一种影响另一种，最终我们将处于一个父亲被视为与母亲同样重要的资源的境地。我认为这非常重要。我想这就是我的主要建议。希望这有所帮助。绝对有用。它们真的非常有用。我认为在支持你所说的一切的基础上，也许还可以考虑其他一些方面。比如，永远都不晚。即使你的孩子一岁、两岁、三岁，或者孩子即将上学，而你只见过他们几次，也永远
too late. There's always a chance to create a relationship and to become a father. It doesn't matter about shame and guilt. We can always work through that. We can almost de-shame this process. We are where we are right now. We can't necessarily change the past, but we can certainly get some of that trauma to lay flatter if it's stopping us from thriving in our relationships with those around us and in becoming a mother or a father. Don't feel invalidated. If people are saying, oh, it'd be better if you just went away and weren't part of this child's life, everyone would be better off without you. That doesn't necessarily mean that's true. You still can choose, so long as it's not a risk to yourself or your baby or, you know, the factors are all safe, shall we say. You still can
不晚。总有机会建立关系并成为一名父亲。羞耻感和内疚感并不重要。我们总能克服这些。我们几乎可以消除这个过程中的羞耻感。我们现在处于这个位置。我们不一定能改变过去，但如果创伤阻碍了我们在人际关系中茁壮成长，或者阻碍了我们成为母亲或父亲，我们肯定可以减轻这些创伤的影响。不要感到被否定。如果有人说，哦，如果你离开，不再参与这个孩子的生活，大家都会更好，这并不一定意味着是真的。你仍然可以选择，只要这对你自己或你的宝宝没有风险，或者说，所有因素都是安全的。你仍然可以
choose to be a father and to be attuned and present and that's okay. It's not silly, is it, to want to be a father? You don't have to let other people get on and do that for you. It's safe for you to explore some of those factors about what that would look like, how that would be for you, so that you can be a consistent father. I think this is some of the stuff that's really powerful is we want children to have an experience of consistent, reliable, safe parents. And in supporting both parents and the systems around them, we want to give everybody the best chance of having that consistency.
选择成为一名父亲，保持协调和在场，这没关系。想要成为一名父亲并不傻，对吧？你不必让别人替你去做。探索这些因素对你来说意味着什么，以及这对你来说会是什么样子，这是安全的，这样你才能成为一名始终如一的父亲。我认为这其中一些内容非常有力量，因为我们希望孩子们能体验到始终如一、可靠、安全的父母。在支持父母双方及其周围系统时，我们希望给每个人最好的机会来实现这种一致性。
Yeah, so that you can be predictable and reliable in a good way, not the kind of parent that's like, oh, they've let me down again. We want you to feel like it's safe for you to show up and you enjoy those relationships. Is that kind of fair to say, Ali? Yeah, I think that's a really good question and a good point to make. I think that there's a lot of pressure for parents in general, but I think, you know, if we're thinking more specifically about fathers, to feel like you're kind of the finished package when you become a dad. And I think what's really important to mention is that, you know, the dads I work with they're 17, 18, 19, 20. And, you know, no one's the finished package at, well, no one's the finished package ever, but we're constantly evolving. But I think, you know, when you're that young, you know, you're going to still have a lot of kind of work to do on your identity, what's important to you,
是的，这样你就可以以一种好的方式变得可预测和可靠，而不是那种让孩子觉得“哦，他们又让我失望了”的父母。我们希望你觉得展现自己是安全的，并且享受这些关系。阿里，这样说公平吗？是的，我认为这是一个很好的问题，也是一个很好的观点。我认为对于父母来说，普遍存在很大的压力，但我想，如果我们更具体地考虑父亲，当你成为父亲时，会觉得你需要是一个“成品”。我认为非常重要的一点是，我合作的父亲们才17、18、19、20岁。而且，没有人是成品，或者说，没有人永远是成品，我们都在不断进化。但我认为，当你那么年轻时，你仍然需要在身份认同、什么对你重要等方面做很多工作，
what makes you tick, what your values are. So it's kind of acknowledging that there's not, there doesn't need to be this pressure around feeling like, oh, I'm not ready to be a dad, you know, I haven't worked on all my stuff yet. Because actually, in some ways, that can sometimes be a really, like, beautiful, meaningful thing. Because you're kind of, I think a lot of my dads model really nicely to their children that actually they're not perfect and they're still working things out and there's still things that they want to achieve and things that they're not sure about and they're learning as they go and I think as long as you're trying your best you know you're seeking out support and
什么让你感到充实，你的价值观是什么。所以要承认，不需要有那种“我还没准备好当爸爸，我还没处理好我所有的问题”的压力。因为实际上，在某些方面，这有时可能是一件非常美丽、有意义的事情。因为我认为我的许多父亲很好地向他们的孩子展示了他们并不完美，他们仍在摸索，还有他们想要实现的目标，还有他们不确定的事情，他们边做边学。我认为只要你尽了最大努力，寻求支持和
information when you feel a bit lost and not feeling, you know, like you're not able to do that, feeling that you have just as much of a right to seek out support and talk to people about how you're feeling as anyone else. And I think we really as a kind of wider society, and particularly as mental health services, we need to really start acknowledging with a bit more kind of seriousness how much of a massive upheaval in identity it is to be a young parent. It's a big undertaking and it requires a lot of support and yeah nurturing and I think that we have a long way to go but I think things are moving in the right
信息，当你感到有点迷茫时，不要觉得你不能这样做，要觉得你有权像其他人一样寻求支持并与人谈论你的感受。我认为作为一个更广泛的社会，特别是作为心理健康服务机构，我们需要开始更认真地承认，成为一名年轻父母在身份认同上是多么巨大的动荡。这是一项艰巨的任务，需要大量的支持、养育。我认为我们还有很长的路要走，但我认为事情正在朝着正确的
direction and hopefully in the future we'll live in a time where you know all parents in whatever you know whatever gender will feel supported and heard and seen and seen as a really important resource for the whole family. That's kind of what we hope to help to move towards through this project. Yeah, and it sounds like an incredible project, but I became a parent at 32 and it was still a steep learning curve. I was ready for it and it was a planned pregnancy and I had done lots of lovely things before becoming a parent. But like we said earlier,
方向发展。希望在未来，我们生活在一个无论性别如何，所有父母都能感到被支持、被倾听、被看见，并被视为整个家庭的重要资源的时代。这正是我们希望通过这个项目推动的方向。是的，这听起来是一个了不起的项目。但我是在32岁时成为父母的，这仍然是一个陡峭的学习曲线。我准备好了，这是一个计划内的怀孕，在成为父母之前我做了很多美好的事情。但正如我们之前所说，
you are where you are. You're the age you are. You are a parent or you're becoming a parent and you can still move forward with your life. This isn't the end of your life. This is the start of a new generation of your life and it doesn't need to feel... It's safe for it to be an exciting thing, but of course it might feel a bit scary too as well. But we can still move forward when things might feel scary. That's okay, but trying, like you said, to get people around you who are supportive, who are going to support you in your journey in becoming a young father is so important, isn't it? Definitely. And I think that just also being flexible in just rolling with what you're feeling from day to day. It's very
你处于你现在的状态。你是你现在的年龄。你是一位父母，或者你正在成为父母，你仍然可以继续你的生活。这不是你生活的终点。这是你生活新一代的起点，它不需要感觉……它是一件令人兴奋的事情，这很安全，当然它也可能感觉有点可怕。但即使事情感觉可怕，我们仍然可以前进。没关系，但正如你所说，尝试让周围支持你的人来支持你成为年轻父亲的旅程是非常重要的，不是吗？绝对是。而且我认为也要灵活应对你每天的感受。这非常
acceptance and commitment therapy kind of way of thinking. But just if one day you feel excited and so in love with your baby and so attached and everything's going amazingly and then the next day you feel like, oh my gosh, you know, I'm totally overwhelmed. I, you know, I'm feeling anxious, I'm feeling low. What have I done? All of these feelings, like, I think it's really important to acknowledge that all of these feelings are welcome. And they're, you know, part of the process and just leaning into how you're feeling and just kind of welcoming that with a bit of acceptance and being kind to yourself as well. I think it's really important and I think without generalizing massively, you know, I think young men are not always that kind to themselves.
符合接纳与承诺疗法的思维方式。如果有一天你感到兴奋，非常爱你的宝宝，感到非常亲密，一切都进行得非常顺利，而第二天你却觉得，哦天哪，我完全不知所措。我感到焦虑，感到低落。我做了什么？所有这些感受，我认为承认所有这些感受都是受欢迎的，这一点非常重要。它们是过程的一部分，只需顺应你的感受，带着一点接纳去欢迎它，同时也要善待自己。我认为这非常重要。而且我认为，在不进行大规模概括的情况下，我认为年轻男性并不总是那么善待自己。
And I think that, you know, we have a, there's a long way to go as a society in terms of making young men feel welcome with feelings of vulnerability and expressing feelings of shame or embarrassment or hurt or whatever it might be. So yeah, I think that's really important. Yeah. And it wouldn't be okay to have an episode talking about children and babies without saying just a quick mention about sleep. Sleep is really challenging. And what I know from being a parent is when we're incredibly exhausted, perhaps these babies, in my case, one of them woke 31 times a night, what I noticed is that the self-criticism, the self-doubt really ramps up. There's more of a vulnerability when we are physically exhausted.
我认为，作为一个社会，在让年轻男性感到可以表达脆弱感、羞耻感、尴尬感或受伤感等方面，我们还有很长的路要走。所以是的，我认为这非常重要。是的。如果不提一下睡眠，关于孩子和婴儿的节目就不完整了。睡眠是非常具有挑战性的。我从为人父母的经验中知道，当我们极度疲惫时，比如在我的情况下，其中一个孩子一晚醒了31次，我注意到自我批评和自我怀疑真的加剧了。当我们身体极度疲惫时，脆弱感会增加。
So please, if you are tired, try to get some rest. Try to ask others around you to support you so that you can get some sleep as well. And that goes for the mother as well. Like, sleep is a big one and affects so many factors, doesn't it, Ali? Right. I would just like to thank you, Ali, for your time in bringing this to our audience and for your really thoughtful, insightful approach in this episode. Thank you so much, Ali. Thank you. Yeah, it's been great. Thanks, Marianne. You're so welcome and do stay in touch.
所以，如果你很累，请尽量休息。试着让周围的人支持你，这样你也能得到一些睡眠。这对母亲也一样。睡眠是一个大问题，影响着许多因素，不是吗，阿里？没错。阿里，我想感谢你抽出时间将这些带给我们的听众，并感谢你在本期节目中非常深思熟虑、富有洞察力的方法。非常感谢你，阿里。谢谢。是的，这太棒了。谢谢，玛丽安。不客气，保持联系。
Yeah, I will. Thank you so much for watching. I hope that you found that to be as useful as I found it interesting. I would love your thoughts. If you're watching on YouTube, please do drop me a comment. Please do drop in a like on the episode if you do find it helpful. If you're listening to this as a podcast episode, please do follow the show. Please, if you're listening on Apple, please rate and review. If you're on Spotify, don't forget, you can always drop in a Q&A and you can still subscribe to the show too. If you're an aspiring psychologist, please do come along to the aspiring psychologist
是的，我会的。非常感谢你的观看。希望你觉得这和我发现的一样有用。我很想听听你的想法。如果你在YouTube上观看，请务必给我留言。如果你觉得这期节目有帮助，请点个赞。如果你是作为播客收听的，请关注这个节目。如果你是在Apple上收听，请评分和评论。如果你在Spotify上，别忘了，你随时可以进行问答，你也可以订阅这个节目。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，请加入“有抱负的心理学家”
community on Facebook, which is my free Facebook group. If you love these kinds of conversations, the growth that can take place from these sorts of interesting, compassionate, curious conversations, I think you'll really like the Aspiring Psychologist membership too. You can join from just 30 pounds a month with no minimum term. And if you're ready for a longer term commitment, we've also got the Ready to Rise program,
社区，这是我的免费Facebook群组。如果你喜欢这类对话，喜欢这些有趣、富有同情心、好奇的对话所带来的成长，我想你也会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划。你每月只需30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限要求。如果你准备好进行更长期的承诺，我们还有“准备崛起”（Ready to Rise）项目，
which is where you can work in a one-to-one capacity with me, Dr. Marianne Trent, to really shoot for your psychology career dreams. However, you might well be a teenage father or supporting someone that is, and therefore none of that might be relevant. But thank you still for being here, and please let me know what future content
在那里你可以与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士——进行一对一的合作，真正为你的心理学职业梦想而努力。然而，你可能是一位青少年父亲，或者正在支持某人，因此这些内容可能并不相关。但仍然感谢你的到来，请告诉我未来什么内容
you would find helpful, wherever you are listening to or watching this podcast. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective, and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected
对你有帮助，无论你在哪里收听或观看这个播客。嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书，以帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我买了它。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，它让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多反思。它也有助于从更广阔的角度看待事物，并提醒我，如果今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。我认为最意想不到的
pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was, and using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
乐趣在于，每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心，每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力真是一种享受。我几乎不舍得读完它。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。